おはようございます田治米社長ですいい天気ですね6学者だ今茨城県のあのものが爆発
できる現場に来ております今日はよろしくお願い致しますと言うけど僕の後輩の
ユーチューバーに誰てめ絵ステーションという男がいるんですけども全然はだ下っ端の
ユーチューバーで今までの動画の編集とかもずっとスマホでしてきたって言ってたんで
多くは優しいんでそんな彼に macbook pro
最高スペックまさん40万ぐらいのパフォを先に買ってあげたわけでございますよああ
優しいです
優しい優しいですがおい
ユーチューバー型パソコンもなると思うんだよねこれ
俺がどうんだよというわけでただてさん40万円のパパを買っているわけには行きませ
ん果て面に挙げた340万円のパソコンが大爆発ドッキリやっていこうと思います
と言う出会いさっきながサーッと適当なことを言ったらパターン私出口なんでちょっ
パソコンか知ってパティ
ああああはい終わりました後ろなん
えっ
ていません
[音楽]
あのれずパソコンを連れたからから早い家族扮するしたい
あ
とか拾う最大ん
me
mishka ってないんです
猛追ターン毎のこれでははいオッケーです
ポツが彼のパソコンですねこれとサイズ感がほとんど一緒のジャーミィのあのもう爆発
する用のパソコン当てるに準備していただいておりますでターゲットが今車でちょっと
出かけてもらってるねこれあーゲットが帰ってきてあこれだパソコンだって思ったこれ
パソコン取りに行ったらヒャッハーツールドキュリやっていこうと思います本当に
あいつ素直でいい奴なんですよくぞ
けどまぁホンギにユーチューバーやってくるのであればこういうドッキリも必要なのか
なと思いまして
まあ彼のためにも僕の楽しみのためにも大はいの macbook を大爆発させて
いきましょう増やし続きセッティングしていきますどうぞよろしくお願います
これがバックされるパソコンですね理由なんですよ
ゆっこに今ケーブルをつないで変化する準備
宜しくお願いしますよろしくんはいというわけでバクハメっていう
完了しました m さんけどちょっといなくなってるんでさぁゲットにも先に0までは
ぐ版の予告をさせていただきますそうすることによって帰ってくる時めっちゃあーてて
くると思うんでその勢いで爆破させていただきますですお電話します
mojo せ
小田でねー
お前がバサ子ば暮らしてやろうかぁ
[音楽]
めっちゃいい合致で本当にもう準備完了なんだよ
早く帰ってこいよ
マジでもがってるからなぁ
はっはっはっ
うおっこれでも慌てて帰ってくると思うんで入ってきたところばっかしようと思います
ねば採決を買ってくるのを待ちましょうぞ
amaran
からあのさあ来た
wh
rar
[音楽]
wh
皇族俺もめちゃんだ入れられるよ俺はください
ほら軍門に任せようますまず常にが邪魔したら
[音楽]
ブーブー俺はぁはぁデー
じゃーんっ
れ jj 育った
ああああああ
[音楽]
うわあああああああああ俺空フィリピンに的な
ん
[音楽]
8 hi ん
えっ
うわぁ
どうぞ
すかマジヤバイっすよでパソコンはヤバイって本当にお前さぁ
自分のパソコンの色覚えてるグレーぬ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
car
me
違う何よそれこれはシルバーです
違うかこれ違うば綺麗だーなぁ
まずやばいと思ったんですよ何でうわっ
楕円形です平枚とだが誰かはユーチューバーなりたいんだろう一枚のですこういう時で
も今後あると思うから
いい顔しとったぞありがとうございます
今後もあのパソコンでがんばれがんばれがんばれますございます
を止めてくれザッハー